in this video I want to talk a little
bit about a form of cancer chemotherapy
and how it works biochemically so if you
recall from the last video we had this
reaction taking deoxy uranium 5 prime
mono phosphate the UMP to dtmp and if
you want the details on the reaction go
back to the other video the previous
video this reaction was catalyzed by
thymine late synthase so what it did was
take basically take our u nucleotide to
turn it into a t nucleotide now this T
this deoxy T nucleotide can later be
used to make DNA now the enzyme that
makes this happen is that middle a
synthase okay so this reaction is the
target the target excuse me of a cancer
chemotherapy drug which is 400 uracil
which can be converted into floral D UMP
fluorodeoxyglucose off 8 now this floor
OD UMP has an effect on this enzyme and
therefore an effect on this reaction so
what exactly does Fleur du UMP do well
what it does is it covalently in here
irreversibly inhibits by mid-late
synthase so it stops this reaction from
occurring so what does that mean what
that means is that no dtmp will be made
part if this enzyme can't work we won't
make this DT NPS well if no DT MPs are
made that basically means that we can't
have T's available for DNA synthesis
right we can't make DNA because DNA
requires a's t's c's and g's so
basically what that means is DNA
replication can occur okay so that means
mitosis and cell division cannot occur
so why is florid UMP a good form of
cancer treatment then well if you don't
already know the definition of cancer or
what cancer is in a nutshell cancer
basically in a few words is uncontrolled
cell growth so cells grow grow and grow
and grow and grow and it's not there the
cell growth is not controlled so what
forms are these things called tumors now
tumors are basically just clusters of
mitotic reactive or
dividing cells so their cells that just
keep growing dividing growing dividing
there's more and more and more so cells
so Florida UMP is a good form of cancer
treatment because these tumors right
these clusters of mitotically active or
rapidly dividing cells can no longer
grow and divide
right so the tumors can't grow so why is
it that they can't grow though so the
reason why is because S phase right
which is the DNA replication phase of
the cell cycle it must occur as a
prerequisite to cell division so if you
recall the cell cycle we have g1 + s g2
and then mitosis and cytokinesis so the
cell in order to undergo through go
through mitosis the the previous stages
need to need to happen you need to
replicate the DNA before you can
separate sister chromatids in mitosis so
if you don't have to like if you don't
replicate your DNA then that can't
happen right so um if there's the DNA is
not replicated you can't the cell cannot
divide and grow right so um so which is
good right we don't want tumors to grow
we want to stop growing right so that's
why forward UMP is a good former cancer
treatment in addition to that more
specifically RNA synthesis otherwise
known as transcription right and
translation which is protein synthesis
are both unaffected now why is that
well transcription is RNA production
right RNA has used instead of T's right
so and proteins they use actually amino
acids instead of nucleotides so what am
I getting at here well RNA can still be
made right RNA uses ease use c's and g's
so it doesn't depend at all on the
presence of T in order to be produced so
transcription can still happen your DNA
that already is there will still be
there but no new DNA replication can
happen right RNA however RNA synthesis
is not affected at all so you can still
turn the DNA that you do have into RNA
via transcription and if that's
happening RNA synthesis is still
happening then you can turn your mr and
into proteins via a process called
translation and the reason why that can
still happen is because proteins use
amino acids and the the fact that there
are no T's available for DNA replication
has no bearing on the amino acid
availability so proteins can still be
made so now there are some side effects
right of this cancer treatment so why
can this treatment to some extent be bad
the reason why is because basically any
mitotically active cells mitotically
active cells cannot divide right this
this drug stops mitosis from occurring
because it stops DNA replication so
examples of cells that are mitotically
active are hair follicles skin cells
immune cells intestinal lining so this
is why people have their hair fall out
hair falls out because the hair
follicles are no longer dividing so
their hair falls out the skin cells can
no longer grow and replace right so I'll
I don't know if you guys know this but
you're the the outside of your skin is
mostly dead skin cells and it's replaced
continually by new skin cells coming
from beneath beneath your outer surface
of your skin so some cancer patients in
side-effect of this cancer treatment is
that their skin loses integrity which
essentially means it becomes thinner
okay and immune cells if immune cells
aren't if the if old the immune cells
are not being you know replaced by new
ones immunity can decrease so cancer
patients can be more susceptible to two
illnesses right or infections excuse me
in addition intestinal lining that's
another set of cells that's continually
dividing and if it's it can no longer
divide and replace those old cells then
this can cause inflammation of the
intestinal lining and that usually is
pretty painful so people will see you
get abdominal pain right so these are
are some side effects
of this cancer treatment right and this
is the reason why so another question
that sort of comes up is why can the
production of tea right like in the
production of tea but not other
nucleotides be blocked and what would
happen if the production of any other
nucleotides were blocked well tea right
is only in DNA a you C and G are all in
RNA right so if we stop the production
or block the production of a you C or G
that would block RNA production and if
we had no RNA no RNA production we would
have no RNA we had no RNA we wouldn't be
able to make proteins and our body is
basically made up of proteins whether
there's structural proteins that make up
you know certain actual physical
structures of our body or enzymes that
catalyze reactions that keep us alive so
there are no proteins that will result
in death which is obviously not not a
good thing so but this this is pretty
this is incredibly interesting right
that this T is only in DNA when blocking
that can actually benefit cancer
patients but blocking any of the other
nucleotide synthesis would be incredibly
detrimental so this is a definitely
interesting I hope you found it
interesting I hope you found it helpful
one thing to bear in mind is I'm not a
doctor so take everything or or an
expert rather so take everything I say
with a with a grain of salt but this
should be pretty accurate for the most
part hope you found that interesting and
helpful and informative one last thing I
am a tutor if you live in Southern
California feel free to contact me via
email I move university at gmail.com and
check out the description below for more
details thank you for watching